come together muslim made once again to
get to clean water families in gaza
105 pounds can provide interrupted water
to two families
for an entire year
check out our sponsors nature's blend
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use the discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh brothers and sisters and
dear friends i'm here with my beautiful
car toyota prius in the back
yep doing a video while my family is in
tesco doing some shopping now today i
want to touch upon a video of brothers
and sisters as you guys know
the filthy scum dirt bag who used to
draw the prophet peace be upon him
in different ways etc that's not our
prophet we know that
and now he has reached his end now
reaching his end
he would have wished if that was the end
and he's not and we know that's not the
end
because now he's going to be resurrected
not only that when his soul is being
pulled out
for what he's done yeah it's going to be
pulled out
uh in such a way that no one would want
to imagine alhamdulillah
he passed away
these people are nothing but toxic vile
individuals
yeah and they bite and die in their rage
because of islam's growth the shahadas
people in the west come into islam and
islam's growth
because islam is the truth and when
somebody is stubborn
in their disbelief they do nothing but
increasing their disbelief
and allah does nothing but increases
them in their disbelief
not because allah subhanahu wa is unjust
but because they are unjust to their
self
and they reject the signs and all they
do is oppose islam
without any basis without even
understanding it so brothers and sisters
i'm going to give a verse in sora toba
verse 46
to verse 40. allah talks about
and there was a group of them and what
would they do is when the battle of
taboo happened brothers and sisters and
the companions were preparing themselves
to go to war and the reason why i
mentioned this because it's
you will understand why when it comes to
the hostile disbelievers and the
monarchy
yeah okay and um be other people whoever
might be against islam
one thing you need to understand is
allah subhanahu wa saying in the battle
of taboo when they were going in surah
al subha mentions that they were making
excuses
and it's by the will of allah did not
want them to join the believers why
because if you think about it if there's
a thousand of us of us going
to a war or wherever it may be we would
want more people because it makes sense
that more people means
more power it would mean that more of us
better because we have more power
in fighting the enemy but the point is
here if you think about it closely
what's happening here is that those
people and allah says in the quran that
they would have had nothing but the
stress and
misfortune and not only that they would
have caused fitness and trouble
imagine if there was 10 20 of them in
africon imagine the process they were
going to do
because that's all they did they would
whisper in the muslims ears should try
to dissuade them
from going um joining the battle
whatever it may be so you can clearly
see that sometimes when we think to
ourselves
bigger than numbers is better not really
because if you have a group of people
who are your enemies within you it's
better that you go to the battle
with 20 of you less but you don't have
five that's going to stab you from
behind
so these people who are trying their
best their utmost best
to dishonor the prophet peace be upon
him salvation
every single muslim billions praise him
yes and we send sanitation upon him
and the angels in the heaven and allah
subhanahu wa tala praises him and his
prison in the quran
so you can do your cartoons yeah you can
do your cartoons
and drinking quran uh drinking the
qurans and speakers kind of like we have
these
individuals who come to the park carry
on doing it well
you do nothing but you aid and help
islam
because your pictures that you draw
that's not our prophet peace be upon him
and yes we will be angry and upset and
let me tell you something
the best way to combat such individuals
with hate
these people this filthy scum who's in
the hell fire now
burning inshallah and may allah destroy
more in there inshallah yeah we're not
we're not we're not
caught in our village we're very
straight up to the point here may allah
increase him in the fire
and burn his flesh over and over and
over again for the
for not only just drawing pictures it's
not just a matter of that yeah his
oppression
and the ripple effect of that and the
hostility people are towards muslims
so alhamdulillah this is a moment of
celebration and it is tomorrow what an
amazing
news for eid this is in no way from
anyone come and say to me it's
hate it's not hate at all he showed this
hatred and we
are happy that someone like him has left
this earth because less hatred would be
spread
till next time assalamu alaikum what
happened today better to brothers and
sisters be proud of your religion
do not sugarcoat your religion we are
happy with islam like we say in our
claim
we are pleased with our lord yeah we are
pleased with allah as our lord
as islam as our religion and with
prophet muhammad sallallahu alaihi
sallam
as our final prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
till next time brothers and sisters if
there's anybody that would like to
accept islam
get in contact with myself inshallah and
we can arrange it
and with salaam we are launching a new
project
uh which we're going to help um
inshallah people to be
and born muslims who want to learn how
to pray to pray inshallah your hate
will never ever stop us but it will be a
fuel for us to carry on
with our mission may allah accept it
from us
everybody make sure you celebrate with
your friends and family till next time
goodbye